et on vous le disait un florian
philippot leaders politiques des
patriotes mène lui aussi son propre
rassemblement le cortège a démarré dans
l'après-midi un depuis la place du
trocadéro pour se diriger vers le
ministère de la santé et pour florian
philippot la france reste en retard sur
tous les pays et qui lève en ce moment
les restrictions sanitaires écoutez le
je me demande si à la fin on sera plus
que le seul pays au monde à mettre en
place ses réflexions et ses passes enfin
tous les pays sont en train de supprimer
tout ça s'attendent apprend que c'est
l'islande hier la catalogne l'angleterre
l'espagne le le l'irlande le danemark la
suède va tout le monde est en train
d'arrêter tout ça ça n'a absolument
aucun sens sanhadja l'ugtg en salle
encore moins avec l'eau micron et il
faut revenir à une vie totalement normal
donc évidemment qu'on se bat mais voyait
que le gouvernement va dans le sens
inverse puisqu'il vient d'annoncer le
certificat leur établissement
n'était plus valable que quatre mois au
lieu de six mois quand vous avez une
infection ce qui fait qu'ils veulent
absolument vendre des doses de vaccin à
tout prix donc ils sont simplement des
vrp des grands laboratoires ils ne sont
pas ministres ils ne sont pas présents
ont rappelé qu'ils sont juste des vrp de
grands laboratoires pharmaceutiques